good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is Friday
September 22nd is it question wise when
Jerry O'Connell is coming on your show
time flies then there's a very
legitimate rumor that people think
you're pregnant he's there yes why okay
dad you did say something other day that
made it seem like you what did I say
shoot I don't know if it was on your
story but you also made a team on
patreon last night like you're trying
oh did I I'm not I'm sorry I'm not let
me tell you why and now it's two things
after the fast my first story was I'm
nauseous hungry thirsty and full at the
same time okay and everyone's like
that's a symptom of pregnancy you're
pregnant I'm like I just fasted like
sorry you're not in tune with the Jewish
calendar um after my vacation I got a
nosebleed for the first time in my life
and people were like that's a sign of
pregnancy you're pregnant and I actually
thought I might I sounded like me yeah I
was having like I was just feeling weird
and I was like honestly this seems like
pregnancy symptoms pregnancy bugs
pregnant yeah it was pregnancy vibes
only um and I feel I wasn't mad at it
okay wait so then last night I like to
address it I'm like you're also mean I'm
just fat like leave me alone then last
night I was talking about how I really
do love getting tan but I don't know if
this happens to everyone but I get like
the worst discoloration and the worst
peeling and if I exfoliate it makes it
worse if I moisturize I makes worse but
on my forehead on my nose like you could
see like I have white yeah like it's
really discolored
and people are like oh my god that's
what happens to your skin when you're
pregnant does it I thought you're
glowing because you're not drinking
sorry I'm talking my dog walker who came
today and is so hot oh yeah girl boy boy
nice and he was like hot here they come
and somebody need like sweaty and I was
like hello Michael Theo loves that BD ya
know he can definitely feel it he he's a
good like a receiver of BD because he
gives it off himself right speaking of
CEO and speaking of pregnancy's our
patreon episode that we recorded last
night we had such a fun night last night
we did be like just like a low-key TT a
fun family night at my apartment with my
new table the boys watched I was gonna
say I haven't had I haven't had a meal
at your new place yet because it was
almost done but the last time I was
there there was no dining option right
so we were eating on the couch but like
that was just me which I love don't get
me wrong but I'm
down to Y on the couch but it's just
hurting my back my coffee table stool oh
it didn't make sense we finally got a
table a booth it was so comfortable and
it was just we had so many kosher meats
and then the boys watched football and
Theo and the girls record in patreon
episode and we took questions from the
toast after dark which is the patreon
specific Facebook group and you guys had
great questions and it was really such a
good episode I keep thinking back to it
and we feel like I went down memory lane
but a lame town memory that I don't I've
never driven on right so it was just
something we're talking about like old
crushes what we yeah ex-boy and we got
so many good questions that were we
didn't I think we literally might have
taken in the whole hour episode like 10
questions because we kept going on
tangent so we're gonna do a second part
and answer the rest of the question
because finally I feel like we're all
like as a community we're past the part
of like getting to know one another like
you know everything so now the questions
aren't like how did you and then meet
it's not a star girl yeah no now it's
like but here's to see what was your
what's the goal lovers are about mix a
theme like right in depth so it was
really great so if you're not a patron
subscriber and you have the $8 a month
you just wanna you know not get one
coffee at Starbucks or you know feel
free and try it out see if we like
opening it back to our boring - well I
was talking about my boring desk job for
a while and like what I would have done
for a podcast like the morning toast and
I would 1,000% have been a patron mber
because like the morning toast gets you
to lunch
but it's that three o'clock grind that's
hard you guys so when you're three
o'clock and you're like how am I gonna
get through the day
honestly patreon.com slash the morning
toast you'll be glad you did
guaranteed satisfaction or your money
back except for that one girl guaranteed
satisfaction or you can cancel or yeah
or you can play it on Twitter but wait
dementia dementia hold on oh yeah I used
to think back in like the times I didn't
really have like a long stint in the
corporate world but the days where I had
a task and was just bored for nine hours
straight like what did I watch and I
really I watched so many inside Amy
Schumer and YouTube that's how I found
to the point where I was just rewatching
unlike SNL clip said I liked so I really
like I'd like to think that if I was a
cog in the corporate machine I would be
watching the toast I know that you would
be and so this is our corporate takeo
when I watch the toast when when I'm not
here I find it infuriating let me tell
you why because I'm not watching
peacefully I'm watching like oh I would
have said this and then I like
especially when Ben's here I just want
to get in and disagree with him so it's
like it's enraging for me Oh
period when I watched it to us when I'm
not here I just have like FOMO you know
I'm like where am i right now that I
can't be there like what's so important
what is so important I don't know I just
feel like it's usually when I'm on
vacation I guess that I'm here there was
like one time I was I wasn't here and I
could and I should have been I get like
the biggest pin on being here do you
well because I really feel like the
thing about our show that it makes it so
amazing besides for you know the heart
and soul it's really just the format
like people can like rely on it and then
when I can't be here I feel like I'm
just like disappointing people and like
I'm like I literally have one job it's
to do this stupid [ __ ] show and I
can't do it sometimes no that's not true
and also as we said on the episode last
night I think you not being here
sometimes makes the episode where you
are here so much better because we have
so much to talk about we still haven't
talked about the Polka King or done here
toasters oh my god your toasters we
don't have till next week you guys it's
Jerry O'Connell day yeah I know nothing
else matters I think this is like the
most excited I've been for a guest by
the way this is excited toast everyone
has been Fergus like even when we walked
in the guys were like this is like the
first guess we've ever heard of no they
had also heard of nos the other you can
write oh yeah yeah she's Olympian yeah
but I literally have a notepad of three
things I need to ask Jerry O'Connell
about okay we'll get you don't let me
forget my notepad I won't let you forget
your notepad if you're on the three
o'clock grind right now listening on the
podcast wondering how you can get some
more patron iconic slash the morning
toast last night's episode was really
fun we're gonna record our next one soon
and then we're gonna do home tours I'm
gonna do mics I'm ready and my home tour
is at least six months away I'm
surprised that I understand I'll hold it
down for the home tours I just need to
get like some flowers yesterday like I
hung two pieces of art and I was shook
literally like sweat dripping down into
my butt crack and I made so many
unnecessary holes because like I didn't
measure I just like threw it up there
and like and it's so hard when a piece
of art has two things and they have to
be leveled
oh my god I was being so dumb I just I
need to call a handyman and just stop I
never had you been coming over today and
honestly I think I'm gonna poach him
from handy you're obsessed with poaching
people well it's not working I'm still
trying to poach an uber driver I'm still
trying to poach a wag walker and now I'm
trying to poach a handy person I just
want like a go-to handyman that I can be
like hey can you come over I have like a
hundred things for you to do because
it's Jerry day I have a fun question
game for you Jerry Jerry Jerry what's
question [ __ ] marry kill okay Jerry
O'Connell Jerry Springer Jerry Seinfeld
okay we're killing Jerry Springer
and we're marrying Jerry Seinfeld
because he is the most money right and I
love sex Jerry O'Connell is that's true
I would maybe slip Seinfeld and
O'Connell II I feel like being married
to Jerry O'Connell it's like every day
every day is a gift but you know what I
would say like one of the biggest perks
of being married to Jerry O'Connell is
like he goes and watch Robbins IV I take
out with anybody Seinfeld and Jeff
Seinfeld are best friends - Andy - so
it's the same and then you also get the
Seinfeld money so I'm 100% marrying
Jerry Seinfeld okay cool no like no
disrespect to anyone it's purely a
financial thing I guess I could get by
with Jerry O'Connell salary it's
definitely bigger than mine but I really
want that Seinfeld money I know that
Bravo play-by-play money I'm so excited
to talk to him about the show like I
know the format no and I also want to
know like when they record it I think
it's like or maybe it's not I don't know
see that's what I want to know we're
gonna have the answers for you okay so
many uh industry questions without
further ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and talk to Jerry O'Connell also
we have some really good stories today I
don't know that I love not knowing the
story it's back when we had a
teleprompter which was some of the
hardest days of my life I would like
spoil the story for myself like while
Jackie was reading I like watching your
reactions to stories one the story
itself and to the story I'm gonna choose
and it's just so natural it is organic
this first story is might me my favorite
story josh groban love you so much if
anybody is a friend of the Grokster
please like tell him that I love tell
him that the toast is a friend can
someone like set me up on it on a date
with him like a friend date yeah
if you're hating kat dennings i don't
think so they were really good for each
other they were but by email I know it I
feel like he can do a little better like
I want well she's fun follow me on
Instagram so he can definitely do better
than someone who on follows me on
Instagram you know someone who follows
me like I think Jared a new writer
chances available.we she falls me he
should date January Jones was that a
good pairing I think she has a boyfriend
I don't know and if I stop Josh Groban
reacts to Katy Perry saying he's the one
that got away Josh Groban was on watch
what happens live last night and a
viewer asked him we did Josh Groban and
Katy Perry days yes it's the best thing
ever
and this sort was like his appearance
I'd watch what happens live last night
like really explains their whole
relationship okay no one was more
surprised to learn that Katy Perry wrote
2011's the one that got away um
singsong another life I would be your
girl oh my god I just want nice keep
going we keep our promises be us against
the world I think I'm doing it yeah
we're doing a great job it's a beautiful
song and I really is that was part of me
one that got away like that was her peak
part of me is the best song ever and
yeah this is actually from that's the
same era yeah well there was the pre
witness era which is the best and only
era the prytt nasarah the print nasarah
anyways no one was more surprised than
the grub stir to find out that the one
that got away was about him sorry I'm
sorry I keep interrupting you do it does
everyone calm the great Justin Oh
Christian okay last year while promoting
her witness album she disclosed to James
Corden that he had inspired the song
saying quote he's one of my good friends
Groban was caught off guard again
Thursday last night when of you were
called in to watch what happens live and
asked for his reaction to Perry's
revelation quote we did date he told a
host Andy Cohen and fellow guest Queen
Latifah
we were both what sounds like such a
great show watch it but it was like
nothing what was on Bravo last night
that much rabbit I only watch watch I
was live when it goes show i watch was
on before a new episode exactly but I
just [ __ ] love Queen Latifah I gotta
get on it was she in the first chair
obviously oh good question yes yeah of
course we were both very private and so
we realized we were better as friends
and we've been very very good friends to
this day she's the best but I was not
expecting that
that was a double take and I spit out my
coffee when I saw that Groban added that
he was confused by some of the lyrics
for example in the first verse of the
mid M folk tract Perry sings summer
after high school when we first met we
make out in your Mustang to Radiohead
and on my 18th birthday we got matching
to choose used to steal your parents
liquor and climb to the roof talk about
our future like we had a clue never
planned that one day I'd be losing you
although it was quote very sweet of
Perry to speak fondly of him in her
interview with Corden Groban said he
listened to the lyrics again was a bit
lost I'm like I never owned a Mustang I
don't have a tattoo an inspiration like
just talking about the one that got away
and then like writing this like their
tale about it right but like honestly
for me Josh Groban is the one that got
away as well of course but like for
America like he's
one of my dream men yeah no I know I
love him so much
Chito and they just want to like support
like I just wanna I want him to know
that like I well I guess I'm a grandma
on the inside but on the outside I'm a
twenty front five-year-old mm-hmm young
woman thriving in New York City about to
move to Cleveland and I love you Josh
Groban music I love your personality I
love your Instagram I love everything I
love the whole thing you know what's so
odd like I think we have a unique
relationship with Josh Groban because we
we really like grew up listening to his
like French music like as an 11 you know
I knew the word so Chhaya know like and
I shouldn't have I don't even speak
Italian well you like everyone's parents
like played you raise me up in the house
and either it's stuck her it did oh my
god I mean you raise me up will forever
be like the most special sorry I ever on
the restart it's the song of our
generation like if our generate it that
speaks for the talent of our generation
and I'm okay with that I'm okay with
that and you know the story of how he
was discovered right it's the best story
David Foster David Foster needed someone
to sing in for Andrea Bocelli like a
stand-in in the studio so he got the
Groban and then discovered the grow up
stir the Grokster himself
wow what a crew David Andrea Josh Celine
Celine ariana grande was discovered by
David I been working together a lot I
saw a video that shook me to my core
tell me sister do you know how to
pronounce our gonna grab a slice Randy I
talked about it with Warren Elizabeth Oh
[ __ ] the sensories heigen Chrissy
Tigan yes you told me about this no I
didn't yes you did you were sitting on
my couch no one was Eman was maybe it
was the snitch I was only at your house
last night maybe was in turn since it
wasn't me it was in turn snitch okay
grandi I can kind of understand tagging
no it's diggin right yeah when people
pronounce your name wrong
well that's what I said on the show it's
like technically we pronounce our own
last name um I understand how this
happened to Ariana Grande it's like if
the whole world call me Jackie
oshri I actually wouldn't correct them
because that's actually the right
pronunciation right pronunciation
because our last name translated into
Hebrew is all sure I know but the prayer
goes ashrae oshri it's literally even
Australia lady taka ASHRAE Yosh Rey
maybe it's Yosh ray no it's ASHRAE and
that's why I pronounce it in Hebrew I'm
indigenous please like don't know I feel
like
the Hebrew is oshri no it's like I'm not
to say I know but the Hebrew is a shrine
so people are saying it right there's no
way Moses came down even the most
religious person Jackie even the most
religious person when they're saying
Austrade they're not gonna say oh sure
but in school like our relations have I
say called a so trees because in English
and that's how it reads I'm sorry I
stand by ostrich right don't call me
anything even awesome it happened to
Ariana Grande yeah and if anyone wants
to mispronounce our last name I actually
would not correct them because I'm not
even sure no and like I'm just grateful
you're talking about me let alone
incorrectly right and you know Jackie O
works too really yeah grunge clawed girl
with no job Dario Dario genuine same
initials
yeah totally breathing his initials are
Jerry oh or cheerio see Jerry oh no will
also ask him actually cuz it's another
scenario see what makes it seem like
he's a Real Housewife of Jose right
honestly it fits perfectly it really
does anyways next story Josh Groban I
just love you I'm so glad we had an
opportunity yeah spoken Groban
appreciation day yeah he's hot too with
that little curly afro I like it he's so
cute who should he date okay well
honestly January Jones was a great call
because she is like so elevated there
she only acts in like religiously she
she lowered herself by being entangled
Maya great once she removed herself as a
contender today Josh Groban we need
someone who like works like who like
films Downton Abbey Giannini emilia
clarke dun dun Wow they also would get
along so well on a personality level
they're both funny Wow Jackie nail on
the head you guys please if anyone knows
either of you set them up on a bike
except I really do still hold out hope
for emilia clarke getting back together
with seth macfarlane cuz i really feel
like i'm in my shift in my soul that
you'll accept mcfarland only deserves
the best woman like a woman who loves
him takes care of him like he is like i
just i just love him and he was dating
her like before that season 1 series
season finale where she likes tribute
and showed her breasts and the whole
world became obsessed with her like he
loved her before that i saw the beauty
in Daenerys before we did right so like
I just feel like any the fees the
founder yeah Seth MacFarlane also needs
a nice girl but like he's also like
here's that Jerry Seinfeld money like I
think he's making like a hundred mil a
year I want to watch The Orb Oh
I bet I heard it's really good anything
he touches except for how don't die in
the West okay but everyone has a flop
but where's Ted three you guys where
said three I love Ted by the way my
friend
Kade has Ted I know he's he works with
Seth and Seth gave it to him as a gift
and likes Kate is like proud of it and
like puts it in his house like he
doesn't even know like how important it
is to me and I'm like can I have this
and how much would you pay for it $1,000
I think I would so much money no I would
I would pay more it's a piece of history
I think that most I would pay like if I
could describe it together maybe I would
do like a crowdfunder by the way the
toasters would help us if every toaster
just gave me a dollar yeah I'd be there
in a minute
yeah oh my god then we can have it in
here right now we do eventually need to
get some sort of bookshelf because I
feel like I have a lot of props a lot of
gifts that people have given us just
like interesting parts of toast history
that I would like to pop up somewhere
like maybe Stephen 17-page email right
things like that there are gavels but
like I don't know it just doesn't allow
for it right now but you know everyone
about you know stay tuned next up
Leighton Meester says gossip girl wasn't
quote the healthiest environment
Leighton Meester has mixed feelings
about her time on Gossip Girl
Shuggie so I'm sorry January Jones and
Jessica rented date for like a very long
time well I didn't even know that and
people have said we've had this exact
conversation before I know that we did
have one episode where we praise Josh
Groban but that was at the beginning of
the toast and it now it's been about six
months and it's time for a renewal of
Josh Groban praise interesting okay
everyone's yelling at us sorry why are
people yelling at us I don't know like
we're doing this for you
I can't for six seasons from 2007 to
2012 the Leighton Meester played Upper
East Side socialite Blair Waldorf
Waldorf on the popular CW series adapted
from Cecily von Ziegesar as novels
Meester had been working for years after
leaving her native Florida behind for
New York in California she has such an
interesting background right and it's
like you think she was born as Blair
Waldorf but she really wasn't she was
born in a prison yeah right yeah as
Meester stand by the way I like how they
alluded to that in Country Strong right
before Gweneth Paltrow killed herself
sorry spoiler alert she dies remember
he's not even about that
and she says she's giving her she's
passing on her sage advice of the
country star startup and she always says
like if you have a stay and go to this
don't soda before your show and if
there's anything in your background like
that you're like hiding come out and say
it and that's like right when everyone
found out the Leighton Meester was born
in a prison imitates art it truly does
as Meester says in the new issue of
Porter edit in Manhattan quote I went to
school with people who had a really
young each felt like they knew what they
wanted to do when they were pursuing it
at 14 she relocated to LA and picked up
small jobs quote a pilot most years some
modeling commercial stuff like that and
then got her diploma at early at 16 and
then I started working more because if
you're a kid and you can work as an
adult it's good for your resume Meester
found success booking small roles in
episodes of twenty-four seventh heaven
eight Simple Rules crossing Jordan
antroz North Shore Veronica Mars and
other hit programs but auditioning took
its toll on the actress who had a few
major connections in the early days of
her career it is such an emotionally
taxing job because people who getting a
call from around their number who are
hiring you or not hiring you are judging
you based on things that are in most
cases kind of out of your control and
hearing as an 11 12 13 14 15 year old
that a great attribute is that you're
really professional is not really a kid
like compliment homeless is with your
mind if you don't take it the right way
it's been important for me as an adult
to pursue other things that I feel build
up my identity in a separate way and
maybe more so than other people that
started working later okay where's the
gossip girl
t-totally the actress was relative
unknown when she was cast for Gossip
Girl it's the best case scenario that a
show could ever go for six years it
doesn't happen often the cast of Gossip
Girl would typically film for 16 hours a
day five days a week I would get there
at 5:00 a.m. and leave at 8 p.m. she
tells a magazine a lot of days I didn't
see the Sun that was like us in high
school Gossip Girl like I never Ferguson
the series also turned its stars into
overnight sensations when I was young
when I started Gossip Girl a lot more
people were suddenly around I was being
looked at if you don't have the right
perspective you can definitely be
confused by people that being nice to
you or judging you for behavior that's
typical of a 20 21 year old making
mistakes but having to do them very
publicly I'm not haunted by that time
but it's been interesting and helpful
for me to look at it and examine it as
an adult I don't think she's what's so
boring right now like bear will never
talk like you know but also like this
just further proves my theory like
celebrities are cool and rich and famous
but lest we never forget that nine out
of ten of them were just theater nerds
in high school that's one of my ass
cherry were you in the theater club in
high school he definitely was and it's
like now they're all cool but like at
some point they were nerds like let's me
not forget right I'm
I feel like there are a few people who
weren't like you just happen to become
actresses like Lupita Nyong'o
no she went to Yale School of Drama and
like her first movie won her an Oscar
like that doesn't happen you know just
sneeze out an Oscar right but so like
that's why I'm Michelle nerd oh my god
and by the way she's from Tenafly around
here and like people I know went to
school with her and they said she was
the most annoying girl and everyone
hated her but like look where it got her
not very far no kidding I love her oh my
god I take that back but I really like
when there are celebrities who like
you'll go back and watch old like Full
House episodes or like random SVU
episodes and they're on there and I
think you don't know who they were when
you first saw it but now that they're
famous you recognize them it's like they
were grinding you know I love to see
like a celeb rise through the ranks yeah
so I don't know it's like when people
like Jennifer Lawrence like every her
first couple things except she was in a
commercial for MTV once like but you
know people who just like Winter's Bone
what's her first movie and it was like
so it critically acclaimed and then she
like got Hunger Games and it's like
silver linings right like that just it
doesn't happen so I like when people
work hard rise the ranks but these days
like with social media it's like you
just you can get a role because you have
a million followers but like here's my
thing I feel like I'm obsessed with
Rosenberg I'm obsessed with Blair
Warbler Walter worth but like I feel
like if I were in that position like I
would be upset that I wasn't actually
her well yet cuz I'm you know life is
just disappointed right that's how I
feel about dynasty like fountain and
kherington is for everything but then
like but then it's like Vanessa exists
Vanessa had a great life afterwards
because nothing was worse than being
Vanessa being Jessica Szohr is way
better than being Vanessa also like I'm
I love Gossip Girl like forever but
Blair and Dan dating like makes no
goddamn Sam and spoiler Gossip Girl
makes no sense watch just a few episodes
like he literally tells the whole world
that her sister his sister lost her
virginity like that makes him sense also
um Kristen Bell being the net narrator
the voice of the narration was I think
an inspired choice yeah she's a grand
that was before she was in frozen and
people like where claim the claiming her
boys that's actually like the dream job
my ex of quarter narrator you just you
don't do her makeup you put your hair in
a bun and you walk over to studio and
start talking or like we do that every
day
Mary Alice on Desperate Housewives like
film the pilot episode we get paid for
every for sure hashing those mark cherry
check yeah that Stephanie think brought
up Jessica's prize because today when I
was waiting for my uber a bus drove by
me and there was two people on the side
of the bus and one of them looked so
familiar I'm like oh who is that who is
that and he played the son of the family
that moved the Applebee's yeah apple
woods have a wood I mean they kept their
some in the basement those episodes like
haunted me forever then there was like
the hot son who like brought the the son
chain who was in chains like meals every
day and I was like oh good he's getting
more work yeah that's what you get like
one day you're in Chains and the next
day you're on the side of the box it's
alright
no actually they weren't I'm the one on
the side of the bus it's not the one who
was in the chance but I unn
we were in a blender and our saving life
that's what the toast is Desperate
Housewives is definitely a show were
three watching except they took it off
of Netflix which is so [ __ ] annoying
as I was like ready to watch it cuz you
read [ __ ] I rewatched it now it was like
four years ago and I would be watching
again there's so much there it's so well
done and at its core it did inspire the
real of the whole Real Housewives
franchise great
that's what's forgotten cuz like
Desperate Housewives is a thing of the
past now and Real Housewives is in its
prime but like let's mean I forget just
even conceptually the name comes from
Desperate Housewives because was like
desperado sides no real assets it was
like OC Laguna Beach yeah the real OC
yes what they called it so it's just
it's just so funny how life works and
how the industry works right it's like
Gossip Girl NYC prep but actually I
stumbled upon Teri Hatcher's Instagram a
little while ago I'm not sure if I
mentioned this on the show and she's a
web show and it's just like he didn't
have and it makes me really sad like she
was at the Emmys year after year they
one year fear she might have one just
like for herself Best Actress and now
she has a web show I think um people
didn't like her look in the industry
other girls still hang and she tried I
think she hangs with him I think she
thought she was the star of the show and
who was your favorite oh I think it's
between I loved Gabriella at the time
but watching it back bree is everything
like she all she does is try and do
right in this world and like her
children disappoint her husband's you
know in her everyone's just
disappointing her and like she really
tries to be her best and I feel like
Lynette is the word no well so what I
was gonna say is I feel like when we
were kids and when we were watching it
we were like Lynette is the worst she
sucks and I haven't rewashed she's the
Miranda for sure and if you look at it
through a more mature lens you could
argue that she's actually the most
relatable and
most realistic and like the
hardest-working and has the best
marriage even though they do end up
getting divorced right but they really
did have a good marriage for a long time
right
and that was me the biggest
disappointment but I like the Lynette
scenes I'd like even though I agree with
you that Miranda is the most relatable
sorcerer on Sex in the City I still want
to fast-forward her scenes
oh I don't that way I actually love her
I bet so if you're like you actually
should watch it right now because I
remember watching it and where can i
watch it it's on enough weight probably
on Hulu I'll give you a login oh no I
have a login but honestly I don't buy
every season and every episode of iTunes
worth every penny and then I'll have it
forever um what was I saying about
Lynette Lynette Bree Bree Terry have
been watching it like it really inspires
you to like want to do your dishes and
like clean tidy up your house so if
you're like in the moving process it'll
make you inspire to get your house in
order
done with Styria lane no I feel like
when I was watching it Gabriela was my
favorite cuz she was just like the
prettiest and had the best like life and
Carlos is so cute and her kids are so
cute Demi Lovato's sister John Tucker
Yeah right but I feel like now watching
it back I would probably just be like
stop making bad decisions right she's
she's selfish and like she's not forward
I'm self-destructive but I think really
bree is the unsung hero like she the
only time she like does something crazy
like and court kill someone is when she
has to like she doesn't she just wants a
perfect life yeah also there's a running
joke in microphones
nicolette sheridan is a an everyday MVP
um there is a running joke in like a
running joke and my group of friends
because when we were all in middle
school we were watching Desperate
Housewives which now that I think about
we were like way too young to be
watching we probably didn't understand a
lot of it and it was like every Monday
because it was always on Sundays we
would like talk about and I didn't watch
the episode where there was a hurricane
and Carlos gets hit in the face with a
plank of wood and goes blind and Rachel
Ashton well you've told this area have I
yeah Rachel Ashton worth like ruined it
for me that Carlos goes blind and like I
lady really I do still don't forgive her
you shouldn't and I bring it up at least
once a week because it's shocking it's
chucking it really is but any okay just
watch it we should actually and for next
like instead of toast movie the week we
should watch like a season at a time
well actually I can't do that because
it's a conflict of interest with my
upcoming podcast that hopefully will be
coming out next month and that's what it
is do you have an announcement to me
well no because the deal is inside yet
but maybe I'll say the idea so that if
anyone else steals it then
it was yours or you're just giving
someone your free idea but it don't say
but you also kind of yeah I kind of just
okay third story now we're moving into
real news because some crazy shits
popping off dogs are reportedly keep
dying dogs reportedly keep dying after
being groomed at Petsmart near what
nearly 50 dogs have died after being
groomed at Petsmart stores across the
country according to investigative
report Thursday that says the company
offered heartbroken owners
non-disclosure agreements in exchange
for hush money payments since 2008 47
dogs in 14 states ok just with a little
bit of context two thousand in 10 years
50 dogs have died and just and they all
the one common denominators that they
happen to be group that like the biggest
chain and it's one dog every two years
at like the biggest change it okay
whatever no one dog every two years yes
in ten years fifty dogs right I think
it's five dogs a year it's not dogs a
year that dogs a year okay and was it
the day after they was room two Petsmart
since 2008 forty-seven dogs in fourteen
states have died following visits to the
nation's leading pet store chain and
third thirty two of them came after 2015
okay that's a little bit of okay that's
when the company was brought by private
equity firm DC partners according to the
9-month probe by NJ advanced media quote
I'll never forget that that last look he
gave me Nick p'malee Oh set up his seven
year old English Bulldog Capone great
name who stopped breathing and died last
year after you emerged from a pet smart
in a shopping cart because he couldn't
walk on his own what was supposed to be
if the team in a grooming session lasted
nearly an hour quote you don't take the
dog the dog to get its nails clipped and
it winds up dead as a doornail the 72
year old owner said through tears of the
47 20 20 of the pups were English
bulldogs and brachycephalic breeds those
with short noses are pushed in phases
that can make it hard for them to
breathe the news outlet found that the
startling number of dog fatalities could
be the result of inexperience training
groomers who are burdened with meeting
daily quotas and rushed to rushed in to
fill staff shortages when the new owners
bought it they demanded six to eight
dogs in eight hours
Marty Fernandez who worked at as a salon
manager at two Petsmart stores in New
Jersey from 2006 to 2016 told the outlet
this is in addition to walk-in clients
the phones are ringing off the hook your
meeting with pet parents doing paperwork
there's always pressure to do more dogs
it was enough to make me quit she said I
can handle pressure I can handle I can't
handle there
holy [ __ ] but they still don't say how
what they did to make the dogs die right
and also like I feel like if you're
backed up just groom them less well
don't stop them from breathing you know
what is stopping them from breathing
make it faster I don't know but just cut
corners like maybe do like one hand of
honestly like this makes it so hard
because as a dog mom myself I find it
very hard to trust people companies
stores like and every time I do
something new with vo I regret it do you
know what I mean like there used to be a
place where our old apartment that
everyone in the neighborhood was like
it's a great like when that's dog owners
would walk past each other on the street
they'd be like oh do you go to waltz to
go to waltz and I'm like no no no and
one dick because I'm I only work like
out of home in the morning so like I
really I'm an ideal dog owner Theo gets
walked in the morning and then sleeps
for two hours while I'm doing the toast
and then I'm back and then we spend the
whole day together so one day I was like
I was out all day and he needed a
grooming and I didn't have anyone to
watch him and I didn't want to leave him
alone in the crate so I send in to this
place which he needed a grooming he got
his teeth brushed - clipped hair all
that stuff and then they also have day
care that if you pay for the grooming he
gets the whole day care and I got to
pick him up and he comes up the stairs
and when he sees me he starts crying
what she really only does when like I
drop him off I camp and haven't seen him
in a few days and I thought that was
beer because it was only like eight
hours and why is he crying so weird and
we get outside and he pees and I'm like
okay then I take him upstairs and he
legit has diarrhea any piece again I'm
like what the [ __ ] so call the place I'm
like what the hell did you do to my dog
I'm like he literally said diarrhea and
peed everywhere and they're like oh that
well that's because he didn't go to the
bathroom when he was here I'm like well
why didn't you walk him there like you
didn't ask us to I'm like so my dog is
trained and you keep him inside all day
so he doesn't go to the bathroom even
though all the other dogs are going the
bathroom inside and you don't walk in
because I didn't ask you to you kept it
inside in a dungeon for eight hours like
I was so mad I will never go back there
again they're like you have to
explicitly say to walk him what's so
weird you can't trust anyone you can't
trust anyone furry friends that's right
when I bring him here it's like so
annoying but like he's in better care
than he would be anywhere else and I'm
just gonna get a crate here cuz he loves
his crate so hopefully he'd just like
relax and Friday is dog day at the
studio so there's I've never seen
another dog except for that big one that
never
I realized I saw a dog last Friday and
then I realized the reason why we never
see them as cuz we're usually not here
on Fridays you know it was a fart I
realized was the first Friday I've been
here in a while kocha but michael
bachelor said Petsmart offered him a
hundred and forty dollars to cover his
vet bill after his old English Bulldog
gunner left a groom left a grooming at
Petsmart in January with bloodied eyes
from hemorrhaging in exchange though
he'd have to sign an NDA and delete a
viral Facebook post about the dogs did
you do it obviously not cause he's
talking about it um well or maybe he
just broke the NDA because this what are
they gonna do now sue him they have a
bigger fish to fry
no also like Michael I will personally
give you one hundred forty dollars just
so you don't sign that NDA and keep that
video going that's horrible it makes me
anything
an da who do you think you are Lala Kent
no totally Kris Jenner
you shouldn't have to sign an NDA like
about that's so sad oh my god I like
honestly dogs dying is like my worst
nightmare I can't even think about it
look at makes me so sad and like
mistreatment of dogs like you know it's
no one's specific fault other than maybe
this management company that took over
cuz like the groomers they're working on
a pet store like they obviously love
animals and they're doing the best that
they can but they're an unexperienced
they don't know that a bulldog has a
shorter nose and that if you put him up
like for the same time as someone it's
not good for him I mean I don't you know
what I don't know but no totally but
like that's why I've alley who comes to
my house honestly it's it's more
expensive it's so worth it because like
your dog doesn't die alley her
instrument styles by alley with two L's
and she takes some amazing pictures of
the yeah and like he just smells great
and she does it in my house and I'm
there and I'm watching and she's so soft
I mean it takes her a long time to do it
and sometimes I'm like why is this
taking so long I'm like Oh cuz you're
careful what's for me
works for me just come in next week and
Castillo is just there's so much beauty
to uncover there that's true I mean I
feel like when where she cut somewhere
she felt like when she grooms steel I
feel like she's really channeling like
her artist and she's really like
Michelangelo like other dogs she's just
you know there's dogs but Thea was
really like a great beauty and his hair
is so much a part of his character so
she really takes her time in sculpting
him yes okay this next story a big
scandal has emerged about Ticketmaster
what taking master but wait I want to
cancer oh like that you should listen up
Ticketmaster was caught enlisting Pro
scalpers for online resales so it's like
teamed up with scalpers to scam people
they like are taking Mouser claims its
fighting scalpers tooth and nail but it
may
than aiding them in private expose is at
CBS news and the Toronto Star is that is
the newspaper Network which is good for
them have shown the company according
professional scalpers even when it's
clear they're using BOTS or otherwise
violating ticketmasters terms of service
the company quietly launched a secretive
ticket inventory system trade desk that
let scalpers upload high volumes of
tickets and quickly resell them at a
price of their choice okay here's my
question
our scalper tickets like legit yeah well
most scalpers it's like they buy them up
from Ticketmaster and then they sell
them at a higher yeah that's like sub
hub but they just do it outside venues
instead of on StubHub um yes or they do
it on StubHub like scalpers could be
syrup they're legit tickets but ticket
like that doesn't give people the
opportunity to buy their own tickets
then there appears a business but
they're making I don't know if you
really care about the concert you can
get it before the scalper no but they're
giving scalpers like premium I mean by
the way that happened to me and my
sold-out show at the Wilbur theater in
Boston a bunch of tickets were bought
and then also uploaded to StubHub and
then like people couldn't get in for the
$25.00 because all my tickets are very
reasonably priced
$35 sorry I'm and now like the lowest
priced ticket it's like $50 on stuff up
because I guess I'm like you're not
making that money no no not at all but
like I respect the hustle of the of the
scalper right nobody says Ticketmaster
is teaming up with scalpers so that's
uncool people work Ticketmaster sales
people caught on camera we're adamant
that they didn't verify whether or not
trade desk users we're violating Terms
of Service including the use of BOTS at
least one rep was fully aware of the
activity plus not only are they like
screwing people who want to go see their
favorite show there they also like
pretend to be anti scalper anti-pot when
really they're pairing up with them to
make more money sorry I'm not I'm not
defending Ticketmaster I'm just
defending the scalper like it's an
honest business no and also scared like
scalpers are scalpers they also scalpers
I get a bad rap like people they do the
same thing as like Christina and Tarek
they just flip houses for more money
they take shitty things and make it
nicer 1000% it's not the scalpers that
are fault here but take a master is
supposed to be like a reputable brand it
should be an even playing field like if
the tickets get released
if Sally from Idaho gets it or if Joe
the scalper gets it they have the equal
opportunity to get it but if
Ticketmaster is aiding and abetting the
scalper then I'm not I'm not
Southers have bought so like that are
quicker than human yes and you just have
to like think about these Taylor Swift
fans no not cool who get her presale
code are ready to buy tickets front row
for like at maybe two hundred dollars
but then like if the scalper gets them
those are two thousand dollars nine
hundred
well you paid it like right before yes
oh my god and I had a good day like the
day the tickets go on sale it's the most
no I had the biggest breakdown because I
bought it on StubHub my they were so
much drama I don't even tell you about
this the day before they tell us with
concert am I getting ready I should put
my tickets I don't want to you know
maybe I can do it on my phone I just
want to take any chances and I go to
login and I can't remember my sub table
login and then I realized my StubHub is
connected to my facebook my facebook
email is my nyu email which i is long
gone and I'm calling and I'm like aching
just humming in my tickets like I don't
know the login and they're like no like
they could literally couldn't get it for
me the Reg will just he's like don't
worry I'm like oh he good he said we'll
refund you I'm like what I'm gonna be
refunded oh are the tickets so I'm
literally crying to this guy
Mario on the phone he was so lovely I
remembered my password I'm happy for you
worth it is it worth it let me work up
how my game down for the reverse it are
you ready for a fifth and final story
before yes I just want to get through
because for the morning okay the
Cleveland Browns beat the New York Jets
winning their first game in 635 days in
breaking a 19 game losing streak after
morning toast show jackieo says she's
moving there so we caught the tail into
the game because Ben and Zack were
watching it and I didn't understand the
significance because I realized that
like the Jets are like the worst like
it's like from Big Daddy Cole Sprouse
they're goddamn Japs it's like always
been a thing and then it's ignored
without Mark Sanchez now like they're
really screwed
I am you Sanchez and so then I was like
Ben was telling me that the Browns are
like this team who like have never won a
game and like their whole franchise
career I'm like what sound I'm like oh
god finally good for the Jets they look
like the good team because they're
playing the words team right but he
earns out the Jets are actually the
worst team because they lost so the
charity last week which is crazy
and they even knew even new quarterback
who is fom Friday he like looks a little
bit like him but like more like a thumb
and he's cute he can get it but he
didn't do a good job last night it was
actually a pretty good game from what
everyone was saying from what I was
hearing but so then just videos of like
the people in Cleveland celebrating are
so funny so funny
they caught a possum and like we're
throwing it around which is not cool
animal cruelty but like a possum I'll
live
also there were victory fridges and free
Bud Light beer in Cleveland after they
won the game it's funny like they knew
like the only game in the entire season
they had a chance of winning was against
the Jets I just like so sad
the Jets is like such a prestigious
state like New York like come on it's so
embarrassing
it's so embarrassing God for the Giants
man just like the timing and the
coincidence is not lost on me like Ivan
here like it smells like sure Cleveland
and they heard me and they were in Korea
heard your cries I feel like this is the
Cleveland's way of saying to me like
move here no this is Cleveland's way of
saying well welcome welcome Jackie we're
winners now with you in our state that
is so funny it was a blur 21 to 17 it
was a tight game tied game when I looked
up at one woman is 14 to 3 so I'm like
go Jets you got it but they did not have
it and it was really my past versus my
future and I remember I left home when I
stopped watching I went to shower before
the game was over and I was thinking
about my past there's my future because
I put that on my story and when I had
left the Jets were up and I was like oh
I guess the Jets won like I guess my
past did wouldn't like maybe maybe she's
a sign and then I found out that
Cleveland won after three years and Bud
Light actually did something really cute
before the win came in um
Bud Light put in these fridges with
chains around them and it said like only
to unlock when the Browns win that's
funny and they did and then it was all
free so good for about light for being
in tune for like getting what if they
didn't win how sad like for just full of
beer locked up for the next like then
the next game and it was like a running
joke oh that's cute and they didn't know
it would be this why now why this game
because I'm moving to Cleveland because
of the goddamn Jets and you know what I
was thinking you do have your show in
Cleveland and I wasn't planning on
coming because our my Bachelorette
weekend it's what my shows October 19
yes and I've tickets available girls no
job calm but just quickly I'm gonna do
see you next week sorry I'll just shows
are sold out you can't come but after
I'm gonna be in Buffalo Huntsville
Albany Cleveland
tickets that girl's on shop comm limited
spots available so I want to come to
your Cleveland Show of course if I'll
have to move my flights cuz honestly I
have to tell you something I have to
tell you something don't because I'm
going straight to
a bachelorette party from Cleveland and
there no it's up like it doesn't make
sense I would literally be going just
heard the joke until a overnight I take
a picture with the geotag Cleveland like
and you know what I could Photoshop it
first that's not worth like 500 dollars
in like rerouting my flight and then
making it more treacherous because you
have to layover in Atlanta for an hour
which is why I don't have to do right
and I will probably I might want to
check luggage for my Bachelorette so I
have like ample options and I don't
think I can do that then check it
luggage on and on so on the one
stoplight Cleveland I see you thank you
for the win on my behalf it means more
than you'll know and I look forward to
meeting you guys in a new time it's
11:11 make a wish I was sherry O'Connell
we're here oh my god he can be with
Jerry O'Connell comes in with a Gucci
bag because we will be taking a two to
three minute break but while Jerry gets
here gets miked up bringing in his chair
if you have questions for him feel free
to comment it on the social card on
Instagram on Twitter YouTube Facebook
will be everywhere hounding his
questions but I'm getting my personal
questions out first because I have a
list of things I need to address so just
stay tuned we will go get Jerry and
we'll be right back
you
take credit for that Heather McMahon
found it actually and I stole it from
her Instagram but important to know that
said he's hot he's hot yeah yeah would
you would I would would you write for
sure of course I would have to go on a
date and like pretend like I don't know
who he is and like I'm like oh your show
house wife is on a show act my way into
his heart I would do more than swipe
right is he who is hotter he or David
beador of Orange County
Shannon's did a majority I think he saw
two hottest househusband I think movie
CEO Billy yeah me too and also he's rich
so because he's married he's like
untouchable so there's not like that
desperation a big Dooley see that's true
it is kind of rude though when people
take screenshots of people on dating
sites it is it's vulnerable it's like
someone taking a photo of you sleeping
it's an abuse I agree but like that's
gonna happen when you go on the app
because you don't know who's gonna see
your picture I guess you have to be cool
with it you know you know pictures that
you're proud of
well sure but also I mean it's like it's
maybe the most important advertising
you'll ever do it you guys like you
gotta hit them hit them angle many of
Ben's friends put Ben in their pictures
on like JDate and stuff and I get sent
all the time is this Ben I'm like well
it's the friend who's actually being
advertised but yes that is that well
actually amazing trick a couple of young
ladies I worked with when they go on
dating sites they would only allow group
shots on or their for their for their
profile pics so they couldn't like be
singled out but see that is frowned upon
because it's technically like misleading
and false advertising um well I mean
upon like further investigation I know
we should be talking about Bravo but
upon further investigation you can be
like that's me three from the right
right any you could what are you hiding
yeah what are you hiding
uh I mean maybe you just don't want to
vote like maybe you don't want to get my
merio singer you're putting yourself out
there right that's an interesting point
actually I see it for that purpose first
of all I mean I have to take a look at
this you I didn't realize that you won
the Superbowl
here as a toaster you guys are super
bowl champions that's so cool
it was at it was a great day for us it
really was the Super Bowl was a great
day yeah I was happy the Super Bowl I
went yeah I went with my father and how
was it it was when did you go down I
went to the one where the New York
Giants won 11 years ago where was it it
was in Arizona we went in Minnesota in
the freezing cold February it was the
best week I'd do it all again or not be
at the Super Bowl ever again I'm getting
even if it's just like standing outside
the stadium waiting for someone to like
let me in right because you guys okay
let's talk about play-by-play because
sure it's genius and we have a
conspiracy theory that we would like for
you to confirm oh did she yes because
the name of the show was supposed to be
real men watch Bravo that was our old
name there was a little bit of backlash
for that obviously people it people felt
like it wasn't very inclusive and at
Bravo and myself are very inclusive
people very inclusive minded people and
so we promptly changed the name we
didn't want anyone to get the wrong idea
of oh but they can still sell t-shirts
and now your brother yeah I have my
t-shirt I think I have a t-shirt too of
my brother right should I go burn that
t-shirt no is it about t-shirt burger
it's gonna become like like a collector
so you should celebrate is this like
your biggest rave coming true being on
the chest no kidding yeah this is it I'm
freaking out
I like I'm like shaking no it is
exciting to sit in the throne here
anyway big deal it really is you're your
own Shawn Bravo where you can really
just like as a as a toaster a toasty
a toast ight a toast to miss Maximus
toasty toasty okano toasty toasty toasty
Oh cinnamon toasty crunchy um look I I
have to listen to a lot of like podcasts
and a lot of information out there of
theories of what's going on in the
braava verse and it helps me to form an
opinion for play-by-play yeah I mean
it's like you have to hear what people
are saying out there in order I mean I'm
sure it's like working in news let me
just let me just say right here Bravo
believably is not news it is if you're
the Bravo world is your news then yes
it's you this is your this is your Meet
the Press sounds like it's like Sports
Center for Bravo it is I'm gonna
actually go one step further and I'm
gonna say it's the Meet the Press of
Bravo but instead of talking about Trump
all the time we talk about thinking
Ellison we talk about Mauricio and James
Kennedy yeah it's uh is it a dream come
true
Yeah right well my favorite thing about
Bravo is watch happens live and I love
when there are traditional celebrities
to come on and like know everything
about their superfans
I love it and so this show is basically
just like a culmination of I loved it
when I saw Chloe Moretz Chloe Chloe
grace Moretz I knew there was a third
name in there on there and she was
talking about Leanne Lakhan and what a
fan she is I mean it just makes you love
them when Jennifer Lawrence came on
there and Jax made Jax oh man it's just
it really like it really because we're
all fans so when you when you see
someone who's like an academy
award-winning celebrity as a bad it's
just it's it's really exciting that said
yeah it's my dream job I can't believe I
get to sit down and seriously break down
with three other people of whether Vicki
Gunvalson has a bad picker row or if you
know Brooks really did have cancer or if
Brooks had I like to refer to it as the
fan sir the fake cancer we understand
it's it's so much fun and I you know and
play-by-play Mondays on Bravo you know
to hear like for example we have a guy
named Brendan Schaub who's a superhot
former UFC fighter just jacked and you
know to hear him sort of break down like
why Bethany was in the right over this
Carroll situation and like Carol
like like Bethany just wanted a friend
and Carol wasn't being a friend
sometimes you need a friend it's it
really made me laugh yeah I just I was
there I was almost like I felt like I
just like eating a pot brownie I was
like what is going on right now we're
just like Carroll versus Bethany I would
love to know personally yeah
I'm team Carroll still wow wow you're
really freaking out
thank you so much Terry for joining us
I'll see you in Sonja's toaster oven
magic toaster oven explain yourself I
think Bethany is requesting too much as
a friend and I think Carol is someone
who you know Carol stated from the
beginning since I think she was certain
in season I want to say season three but
don't quote me on that
you know when Carol started out oh no no
see Carol was much later that season
three I think whatever you know Carol
stated like I'm not like I where I
really had that first like there was
that first scene that they had enough
furniture and Carol was like I don't do
that I think she liked they were like
let me give her a tissue through her
pillow and such as wipe your tears on
that like I gotta tell you I'm not a
very emo you know person you know I
don't wear like skinny black jeans
although these are pretty skinny like
like I'm not an emo but like even I
would like you bet that he was crying
like crab or a tissue and I give it to
her
like Carol was just like I don't I don't
do this yeah I don't do remember she
said I don't do hugging but then she did
do it so that's misleading um I hear
because she was obviously they found a
way to have a friendship that works for
both of them or so we thought we're
Pathan was a friend to Bethany and and
like she could handle I have a couple
theories um I think Carol started
hanging out with Tinsley yeah and I
think that upset look like friendship
triangles we've all been yeah it really
make out it's about to happen
when there's a triangle someone could
get mad mmm and someone could act out
and I think Bethany was that person who
acted out Bethany was
I think I think their argument also
started it's something you had to really
listen closely but sexy salad Adam you
know who I'm speaking about who dated
Carol and he wins nice pretty hot guy
wow you do go deep you should be on
play-by-play I know
Oh only are you gonna have other people
other genders yes we are gonna have
other other genders that was a cruel
rumor that was out there that we were a
men only show I don't know what kind of
Handmaid's Tale crap they weren't
throwing toasts we don't see gender but
if we did we would see both on your show
I mean you're literally going to see
both yeah I'm so sorry I have to check
with my Bravo specialist Cheech are we
allowed to talk about like special
guests who come on like she says your
dad my wife is going to be someone who's
Alexis Meade that was one of the things
on my list do you do you feel it
actually sounds like a housewife but no
Alexis Meade was my wife's character I'm
just such an important character such as
special a trans character
can you explain what it's like to go to
bed every night with Alexis mean you
know my wife and I my wife and I we've
been we've been married now for coming
up on 12 years that's like even she and
I are like how did this happen we
thought two years tops right tops
three maybe but we somehow stuck it out
you know what the trick is have children
and then you dislike them so much you
don't want to get divorced because
you're too afraid of like one of you
getting stuck right and then spending
like a long time with them all right
yeah I understand I don't know how we
met oh you know you know that we made it
Bravo I believe that too we have a
television in our bedroom and we watch a
majority of our television in our
bedroom and a majority of that TV is
Bravo and it's like a discussion for us
who was into Bravo first her my wife
yeah okay that's usually how it's um
definitely my wife and you guys are too
young to remember this but there was a
okay there was a character named Teresa
Giudice oh please honey Jersey my right
before middle school watching that
reunion part three after she flipped the
table right
well she it was that table flipping up a
social worker I'm sort of it was like it
on in the background and I was usually
doing like fantasy football on my
computer or something and then there was
a table flip and Teresa referred to
Danielle Staub as a prostitute
constitution for engaged 19 times and I
remember I got out of bed and I like got
right really close to the television and
I was like who is that and my reg was
like oh that's that's Trey and I was
like what's going on here she was like
she's in she red cop without a badge and
Danielle's have Constitution Wars I went
well why she flipped me the table and
she's like well she's mad at her he said
pay attention please and I was like what
is this show and it was like it's the
house I've been telling you about it and
then we kind of knew Andy cook going
through a few friends honey
and that's when watch what happens live
started on Sunday nights and I mean I'll
tell you really where it happened is um
soon after that a year later because
melissa gorga was not on house jersey at
that time so I think the next season
don't quote me on this I'm sorry I don't
know the specifics but the next season
Melissa Gorga was on house was and she
was a New Jersey housewife and Therese
Trey and Melissa were fighting a lot and
I went on watch what happens live which
was only on Sundays it wasn't on four
nights a week kids it was one night a
week it was a special occurrence I mean
it was almost like gathering around the
radio listening to the president's
address here and the Cohens gettin come
on Sunday night but it was always you
know and the housewives is only on on
Sunday night so watch what happens live
oh come on right after the housewives
and it would usually be someone who was
one of the housewives I mean you you
would watch it to gather information I
don't even think the internet was around
back then well it did start his web show
much like this house right right and so
Andy who was a friend of ours said hey
want you to come on watch what happens
live and I was like oh wow yeah anyone
and you're gonna come on with Teresa
Giudice and I was like oh my god and I
met Joe and Teresa was there and I was
like shaking I mean yeah you know I I
mean it was like it would be like
meeting the print like President Obama
and like the President Obama sorry kirb
kirb administration's but I I was
sitting there and then and II said to me
you know on the show hey what do you
feel about what's going on you know me
and I went listen Teresa we love you we
love you tre you had us all a
prostitution [ __ ] but the way you're
treating your sister-in-law it's coming
off as if you're jealous of your younger
sister-in-law like you shouldn't be so
rude to her and she was like well let me
explain myself and I went you can
explain yourself I'm telling you we love
you but this isn't a pretty color for
you and the next day I took my kids to
baskin-robbins and this is this is going
crazy kids to baskin-robbins and the
lady who worked at baskin-robbins I've
been going there for years with my kids
the lady who worked there never said
anything and the lady who work there
came from behind the counter and she
went what you said to Theresa last night
was a hundred percent correct I couldn't
believe you were saying it yes
that was amazing and I knew at that
point I and like the whole Bravo verse
it was tapping into something that we
were all becoming like seriously
emotional she was like I have a sister
and like my sister was treating me Ruby
and it's like everyone can relate their
lives somehow to Bravo you know and it
really like that was my first taste of
like oh I'm gonna get into this and when
I go on watch what happens live I'm
gonna bring it and bring an opinion and
I think that led to Braavos I'm sorry
that story took longer than any enjoyed
it episode you've ever dealt with them
so sorry Bravo say that Lake is way
faster than that easy so working for ya
um it's like the view
it's
four of us at a table and we bring up
topics and I'm basically Whoopi and it's
the view and we just sort of break down
things that are bothering us that week
and it's it's it's really it's really
interesting it's just it's um a guy
named Dave Holmes who's a writer for
Esquire former VJ at MTV Michael yo a
guy whose entertainment reporter has a
show on Sirius is also comedian I ran
into him in one of our shows he is a
comedian
everyone's got funny different takes and
we and there's a debate that happens you
know I mean listen when I said I was
team Carroll it upset our other co-host
Brendan Schaub um really funny guy you
know set him deeply a great deal I said
well here's my question for you because
this is something I feel like we
struggle with it's like once you get to
a point of talking about Braavos so much
and then you actually get to interview
people from Bravo it's like I get all
these like really pent-up strong
feelings for example about Leon Locke
and I think what she did to janitor last
night was not cool but then Leon came on
the show yesterday and it's like you
have to separate reality from reality TV
yeah a little bit I mean it's sort of
what's really fun about Bravo is that
it's kind of real life you know I mean I
think Bethenny and Carol are super mad
at each other oh for sure I don't think
they're gonna be friends anymore but
like if you're out here talking smack
about Bethenny and then Bethenny gets
booked on the show is that like awkward
um I've never said anything disparaging
about Bethenny I don't think I would
ever personally say anything rude about
Anthony I would never question whether
she has a career or not you know I would
never I don't think I'd ever say
anything mean-spirited but I would
probably apologize for saying I'm sorry
I said I was Team Caroline morning toast
it's I it's just how I feel I can't um I
I can't shy away from that no you cannot
and it's my passion it really it is
definitely a hobby there are a few other
feuds that I want to take your pulse on
yeah teddy bears Erica I thought
was a little rude to Teddy last season
but that said that said I think Teddy
was like sort of going to crying a lot
and playing and leaning into it you know
what's funny it was um the tactic I
enjoy watching on any of the house side
shows is uh what did you say about me
why did you leave my house what no
you'll probably say it to my face you
know I like someone to throw a glass
down okay well let's deal with this Java
right now you Beast
I think Teddy sort of went inside and
was crying and was looking for attention
that way and it's just um it's not
entertaining television I that said
here's where it gets weird
I met Teddy Mellencamp at Denise
Richards wedding I'm a little toasty
thrown and lovely beautiful woman so she
made the same experience because we
actually we are staunchly tamerica him
in turn we talked a little trash about
Teddy
then we met her and she's the coolest
gorgeous radiant beautiful has a
relationship with her husband
I've read good things he's great he's
cool he's hot mm-hmm you're absolutely
right when I met them it completely
changed my view of them I'm a hundred
hundred percent in agreement with you it
does get a little difficult for me
because on Bravo's play-by-play we have
to be opinionated therefore I have to be
a little critical of the Housewives and
it might get a little awkward yeah yeah
Denise Richards Andy Cohen is very good
at separating church and state he's
really good at it
yeah yeah although he didn't yet like
Carroll a couple times I don't shoot him
first okay I want to hear her talk I I
thought he was a little less like
Switzerland than he usually is in that
New York reunion you know sometimes you
just gotta step in well and also I think
it didn't help that LuAnn wasn't there
because no one was really speaking on
Bethenny as we have are even letting her
speak so I think Annie did jump in which
we needed otherwise it was it looks like
before blondie knees had decided before
to just talk over Bethenny and yell so
that anything she said couldn't audibly
be hurt and that's not fair
no I I think the countess not being
there was definitely almost like you
know how sailboats have like large keels
that like keep it steady I believe you
she's like the keel that like keeps
everything sort of together in line yeah
yeah I want to ask you about Michael
Rapaport is he gonna be on the show um
he listen he's a personal friend of mine
I love him a lot I know he is highly
opinionated about everything on Bravo we
would be honored to have him on yeah you
guys are like the alpha males of men who
watch Bravo I do have to say he is
probably even more outspoken than I you
know attention yourself yeah I try to
well I try to also like uh this is
what's so great about Michael Rapaport
is that he has a thought about a
housewife that he says it I actually
like before I talk about Teddy
Mellencamp I try to be like okay how can
I pull up how can I politely word this
instead of calling her a crybaby okay
like he would you know Michael rabbit
any Mellencamp is a crybaby man stop
crying dry rot
get into it don't mean Erika Jayne push
you around like that would be Michael
reward as opposed to me going I think
any sort of reverted to tears to get
attention as opposed to standing up for
herself like that's how I preferred a
woman okay but I'm a huge fan man what
name you guys one housewife you would
bring back if you could um I did like
Phaedra Parks a lot Tim um I know she
did some heinous things on honored land
like really the criminal law was really
bad heinous act but I really liked her
mentor Apollo was a superhot house
husband I'm just like such an
interesting dynamic with the prison oh
well I mean it's just an amazing look
it's an amazing anytime here's like a
couple here's a couple things that
happen obviously divorce happens in
pretty much every franchise every every
franchise her husband's going to jail
happens pretty much every franchise yeah
sometimes housewives go to jail um
sometimes sure Oh
New York New Jersey yeah I mean yeah a
lot um a couple of been to prison in New
York
divorce prison coming out of dating
after a divorce always a common theme
hmm
husbands who try to butt in and be in
the biz and be in everyone's business
Jim Jim Jim Jim Shane on Orange County
getting in the middle getting right in
the thick of it I love I love how all
these themes sort of sort of happen at
the same time it's great
listen it's honestly it saved my
marriage with my wife and I it really
has if you if Rebecca was a housewife
what kind of house husband would you be
would you be a PK holding a diamond or
would you be much more reserved like
Mauricio I would get into it a little
bit I would would like I mean I guess I
guess we'd be in Beverly Hills because
we live in we actually live in Calabasas
home of the Kardashians do you live in
the same gated community as them we do
not we live in the poor section projects
you live in the poor section of
Calabasas we live outside the Kate's we
do see the Kardashians often do salads
that they eat we do we go there a lot
what's the place called um it's called
health nut delicious we do I get very
excited when I see them I'm always
trying to get on that show you realize
it's on a rival Network
no it's on there NBC Universal I like to
think of use my rival no I want to have
like I want to have a beef with them
come and actually play my players way
better than anything on E
um oh I do I know I'm always talking
about Bravo but I do love that boxed
show that's so really yeah and Dubrow is
shocked that those guys are not Bravo I
who else is out in Calabasas Oh Denise
Richards is out there but anything
she'll fair at the housewife and what
are your thoughts on her getting paid
four million dollars for the season how
much is she four million that's the
rumor mm-hmm no that's the jam the truth
dealing else that I need to get a raise
on my plate what the what are you joking
me four million four million dollars
[Music]
freshmen here's the Vanderpump bethenny
a few others make somewhere between one
and four million
and Denis obviously for four million
dollars Denis better be like someone's
going to jail yeah I want the nice to go
to jail I want to see her I want there
to be a divorce after this wedding I
want there to be a fight Tom I want
Charlie Sheen
I want Charlie Sheen for four million
dollars hmm what she is getting four
million dollars reported and other
various reputable news outlets including
the morning toast
I love Denise Richards it was such an
honor to be invited to that wedding I
couldn't believe it
it was amazing it was just it was really
a beautiful moment it really was and
that's like we're your two worlds really
are now crossing paths yeah I guess so
you know it was a beautiful ceremony
her husband is hot AF hot he is I'm
sorry
hotter than Mauricio Wow Mauricio is now
second on the totem pole ready for you
actually everyone knows the hottest is
kid Todd kandi okay we're gonna throw
the audience questions but before we do
I have to run through my list of things
I want to talk to course one of them was
Alexis Meade so I can just delete her
Mike oh right my wife plays like speed
it's so funny when you said Alexis Meade
to me because I've been talking bravo
Bravo clay my boy I was like which
housewife is Alexis Meade I was thinking
like oh man that's gotta be some Rando
like it's gotta be from Orange County or
look at atomic or something Alexis
Alexis it's so funny it's like so now
that I'm on Bravo play-by-play like I
have to like get like everyone's
questions and names right or people that
speaks to their level of bringing it on
the show are they memorable or not you
know what wonders are really interesting
Jeff yeah she was a two-season wonder
but such it I feel her like her absence
at all times
oh really yeah she was so dynamic
actually come back to haunt rehearsal
except then she brought it into
anti-semitism which you could never do
as just person myself it wasn't cool she
was saying something about curvatures in
the Jewish star like it wasn't good I
don't know it was she was weird yeah it
was like a Wiccan or something right
and now she's divorced too so oh really
yeah member she's got those parties with
like the stripper is she was
yes you want to know what was really
interesting to me is um on Orange County
which is currently on which Bravo
play-by-play comes out of which is a TV
term for we come after we're right after
them I'm sorry I'm still learning all of
it my home myself I'm sorry if I'm slow
but the Jeana divorce storyline is crazy
because I don't think we've ever seen a
divorce unravel on a new so quickly so
quickly we we meet Mario Ramona and
Mario Ramona and Mario and then a
divorce happens you know even if even if
weddings aren't even if relationships
aren't going that well if you meet if
you remember Camille and Kelsey yeah
Beverly Hills had a season we saw him
there I mean he was only in like a
second on the first episode hello really
Brooke Camille on to divorce her so that
she kind of had a life afterwards and he
almost did her a favor and that's what I
think Gina's husband did and that's what
we are conspiracy theorizing that
Cameron Wescott's husband is doing I
think cam cam II and
court he's a tough one to remember Roger
this need like
cam in court court right yeah and it's
also like gender ambiguous like cam in
court you know why because there's also
Courtney yeah forget it um Cannon Court
I think they have a good relationship
isn't that strange
yes very III can't believe him saying
that you know he says some offensive
things like I think it should be at home
and I don't think you should be working
and that infuriates me but they weirdly
have like he is I just don't think he
has the ability to be like hey honey I
hope your pink dog food company does
well let me know how I can help you out
I think because he's like a weird like
businessman yeah I think he's like he
can't separate like the fact that it's
his wife and he's like look um we need I
need to see police is I need a
distributor and if we're doing this as a
business this is how I talk to business
people like I don't think he has ability
to be like hey honey I hope your job
goes well let me know how I can help out
I'm always here
really proud of you like yeah like
that's like some basic spousal stuff
right there like even if you're you know
even if my wife is doing something crazy
like my wife did like um needlepoint for
like a while I I think what she was like
you pregnant you know so she was like oh
there was a lot of sitting so I was
doing needle points I mean it was like
pretty useless stuff I'm sorry
needlepoint people I don't mean to I've
offended Wiccans and needlepoint you
know pointers so sorry I want to
apologize to all needle pointers but I
was like even in my head I was like this
is pretty useless like my wife is doing
needlepoint but I'd be like yeah that's
that's a great needlepoint that you're
doing I'm really proud of you like I
would at least like was somewhat
encouraging it's like 101 being a
husband like I don't think anyone ever
sat court down and said like hey dude
you can't talk like that hey these
things you can't say that you have to be
encouraging and I realize no offense but
a pink dog food company is maybe not the
most sound business plan ever I mean no
definitely I don't know if you guys have
pets but why do you pick out the healthy
dog yeah not the one that makes their
poop pink right I mean and they're
colorblind tell me but I think you're
just saying if the poop is pink no
that's a positive side effect if they
put glitter in there yeah and that poop
was glitter maybe some perfume you know
what I take it back
Cammie this is an amazing I want to I
want to Shark Tank that okay the other
things I want to quickly run by you is
you upload a video to your Instagram
history of you watering ice cream and
you reference rainbow sprinkles as
different colored sprinkles and I just
want to know what kind of like
cult you grew up in that makes you say
weird things like that I've always said
different color sprinkles listen I look
we're all on the interwebs so I tried
something yesterday I don't know if you
saw those Kanye ran yesterday I was
trying to emulate those Kanye Reds no
one got that I so then I immediately
went in and I edited and I hashtag did
all Kanye yeah I didn't want a KAG Kanye
because I don't want him making a rant
about me and I do see him at the
Calabasas comments and I don't want him
yelling at me in the parking lot
so I was trying to do a joke on that no
one got it everyone just referred to me
ordering oh I was trying to do a thing
we remember he was like hold on a second
yeah so I wanted to say hold on a second
there's a mr. softy here and then I was
gonna have me ordering a mr. softy and I
don't say rainbow sprinkles I say
different colors wrinkles why is that I
don't know man I think it's might be a
New York thing like somebody backed me
up here we're familiar yeah I mean I've
always called them different color
angels I'm from Manhattan
no no so our way and everyone to see the
light calls every bus we go where'd you
go to high school from Oz oh wow I went
to Professional Children's School oh
you're so professional okay other two
things I want to talk to you about
really quickly I was in Denver about a
month ago did you partake in marijuana
no I couldn't first of all I don't smoke
where I'm at but I wanted to go I wanted
to go to one of the places but the green
plus sign and to confront anywhere
apparently they're everywhere like a CVS
right I saw a million CVS is it and see
one dispensary I think you can buy like
I think you can buy marijuana they're
like you can buy those Fig Newtons at
every deli here in well I didn't see it
so for as easy as it was actually shows
like big news as someone who absolutely
loves Fig Newtons I'm like the only
person who defends them they're
necessary but I was in my hotel room
just like killing time before my show my
sold-out show tickets belabor um I was
watching Bravo obviously cuz they have
it in every hotel room and they were
playing a movie which I hate when they
gym it's like just give me old
housewives I don't need a washer and I
was about to get the shower and the
credits came up and it said Beyonce and
I was like and I'm like oh maybe let me
watch this movie and there's a teacher
so but I was like what yeah and I
proceeded to watch the best movie of my
entire life sure called obsessed
obsessed I'm sorry and you are in it and
you play the bad influence coworker
right and I just like I needed to talk
about that movie because I can't believe
I left when it lived 24 years without
ever seeing the movie and tell me about
what it was like working with Beyonce
and Idris Elba was very exciting because
I was a huge this is before you guys
were born there was a show he was in
called The Wire and I was just in all of
him in that show he is cool man he is he
is like as cool as you think he is how
he comes off like that's how cool he is
right but also like put in like a
British accent oh yeah well he's just
like I mean literally like I just like
sit with him on set and he'd talk and
I'd be like yeah that was me
session with them which got a little
weird for everybody cancers will hear it
yeah I uh what can I say about Beyonce
radiant beautiful IRL mm-hmm really like
I think like I know she's an amazing
singer an amazing style and all that
stuff really and like obviously fashion
and photoshoots and jay-z and title but
really what we forget like really what's
really special about her is just and I
don't judge people physically but how
like gorgeous she is she's like super
model cool yes no like no one who looks
like her she's known as basically I
don't want to say like a teen singer but
that's she got her start as a younger
pop singer in a band in Destiny's Child
but she's like supermodel gorgeous yeah
and it's not it's not like contoured you
know what I'm saying this is like tota
it's like for real yeah it's like her
face and it was like it's also not like
woke up like this and I'm not I'm not
pinpointing anyone it's not enhanced in
any way it's not something that um was
purchased this is like a gift from God
that is her beauty but also like she's a
girl from Houston and she's like super
polite says to everyone like yes ma'am
like no sir it's crazy to see Beyonce as
like a polite nice and she doesn't have
to I have to say if I were Beyonce I
would I wouldn't call anyone sir give me
that I'd point just even if I didn't
want things I'd say give me that I want
that yeah it to me bring it here and
bring it here no I'm not getting up yeah
I just want anyway
so it was like an amazing experience and
it was just an amazing movie of course
yeah Ali's like it was just every turn
it was such a crazy minute sure I loved
it um speaking of one of my favorite
shows that you are in scream queens
okay sure I took such a dynamic
portfolio with such a dynamic portfolio
I'm super fun to get in that Ryan Murphy
camp you need that Ryan Murphy money
well I mean it's not even about the
money it's just um it is everything he
does I think I mean that Gianni Versace
show was sick the oj oj show mm-hmm
it was really fun you know i was
directed by a guy named Brad Falchuk who
he's married to well engage engage I
thought for sure they were getting
married this summer I was really waiting
for that well I think my imitation
didn't come so I I can tell you that
they're not gonna marry to the next
eight weeks because my invitation hasn't
arrived yet right ah that's cool that
you were going I guess I guess all you
like web yeah I don't know I did at one
time go to Mexico with Gwyneth and me
and her and Brad really hit it off we
may change phone numbers or anything we
just like had a quick a couple meals
together but I feel like the impression
was lasting from a breath sure um well
you guys are moguls in like on the
interwebs I mean I said more than others
you should I think you should be invited
me too
it was just fun to watch them watch them
work it was really exciting it was like
it was like the the pedigree of what
they do what were there and also it was
super fun to see like Billie lourd and
totally you know oh yeah it was
star-studded it was it was really fun I
felt like I was um I mean as I do right
now I felt like I was part of something
cool you know well it was really cool
and short-lived and I miss it yeah um
poses what role that you played you know
it's so funny it was sort of their
network version of American Horror Story
right um like a sort of a younger
version and I just I mean listen we got
two good seasons out of it yeah how were
you watching my last comment before
Jackie pulls up some questions from
Instagram it's not more of a question
it's more of a comment I just think this
is a really important full circle moment
for me specifically because um when I
was a student at NYU my first day before
any classes may Dorian
at Beacon Theatre yeah and Nate a
speaker and it was Jerry O'Connell oh
yeah I was there that's so funny I know
you were great I remember you sex I've
met you but I'm sure I was better was so
funny I mean it's so like just just so
like paint the picture there's a welcome
Frosch like a woman freshman like play
almost like an orientation but they rent
out a huge theater I mean um it was the
Beacon Theatre yeah and so I I went to
Tisch School of the Arts at him while
you 100 years ago but the Dean of Tisch
said hey listen we want like sort of a
younger kind of recent graduate to come
and say something and I went yeah sure
oh I'll definitely comes and it was such
an honor to be there cuz you'll find out
as you get older like you really like
you sort of get really warm and fuzzy
feelings about your boy you're proud
violet yeah you I'm not so I I went
there and like very distinguished like
Dean Campbell was a Dean of Titian she's
a super distinguished woman and she was
like I'd like to announce our next guest
who graduated from Tisch he was just
like you guys as an incoming freshman
just a few years ago he's been in such
films as stand by me he was in you know
obsessed and he's recently and I just
hadn't come out recently in piranha 3d I
have no whole like 10,000 students 10
doesn't go crazy were like so frontal
nudity and come up and bite my spring
break bite my privates and it was a
crazy Spring Break it's like so funny
nudity cursing movie and like it was so
my baby here and she was like in the
backstage she was like why was there
such a reaction to that piranha maybe it
was like Dean Campbell it's a crazy
movie maybe we should have like left
that one oh that is hysterical anyways
we have a lot of questions for you so
I'm gonna happy let's go yes our own
personal selfish question yeah totally
silent Rebecca mean we met on on Jase
white I'm joking you girls
for 12 years you were speechless
you were speechless guru een is a Jewish
life girls
okano you were speechless like their
this the silence in this room that maybe
was the most shock you've ever been oh
my goodness that was maybe the funniest
thing I've ever said in my life
you were speechless but so you didn't
mean we we met at a UH this is gonna
really date us um we met at a maxim hot
100 party do you remember that periodic
coolest it was my wife what my wife was
on on Maxim Hot 100 List and she was in
the VIP area of the party and I was
there with like 15 guys and we were in
the non VIP area and I had met her once
before and she was newly single and I I
met her once before and I was like
waving at her at the at like the velvet
rope and there was like a security guard
was like hey man you can't come come in
here you don't have a glitter glitter
bracelet no I'm with her I'm with her
and I was pointing at her and Rebecca my
wife got up and walked over to me and
she was like oh yeah she was like hey
how are you and I kissed her and
everything and the guy was like all
right you can go in and I went in and
she was like like how are you like like
um I think she even said like who like
what is your name again and I was like
I'm Jerry I eat that one time before I
was like hey I really just wanted to get
into the VIP area Thanks and I was like
is it okay if I said sit down with you
guys and a little skin scandal oh so um
she was on a
date with she was newly single she was
on a date with another man no no one
famous actually whose initials are Ryan
Gosling I'm kidding that's a joke I'm
dumb joking um but you did your friends
um a hundred percent ditched my friends
and hung out with her for the rest of
that party your lives her friend
as I was leaving said take her phone
number
she'll want to go out with you and I
wouldn't know she's with that guy and
her friend was like Minnie Mouse trust
me she's gonna want to go out with you
and I got her digits and and that was
that that's a good friend yes we're
still very good
okay how was it eating the atomic
fireball on the set of kangaroo jack for
those who don't remember I was in a film
called kangaroo jack about an animated
talking kangaroo I had to eat a hot
candy and it burned my mouth oh so
someone's alarm got a week and they're
like stop talking no I had to eat a
piece of candy um I don't think it was
actually like a fireball I think it was
just like it was like sweet but I think
it like a sugar rush from it
understood okay so you've met a lot of
housewives who was your favorite
housewife like not on the show like in
real life and 2-fold who disappointed
you we talked about Teddy Mellencamp
she was pretty I loved meeting Lisa
Vanderpump I'm just not agreeing with
anything you're saying and um my wife
and Lisa Vanderpump have a texting
relationship well tell your wife not to
trust her why she's very duplicitous
yeah um I don't think so
I don't um I think I mean I think she
throws shade and I think it's disguised
as true shade because it comes with a
British accent but um she sort of picks
sides and lets you know I don't think
she's duplicitous she's behind the
scenes and manipulative in the sense
that she 100% told Brandi to bring that
okay
magazine to Mexico I mean when it gets
involved with the todd's and Brandi I
think a lot of stuff went down because
we don't know that I couldn't believe
that mr. Todd was like Brandon you are
dead to us I know it's been an even one
I want to talk to you
so I think we don't know the full story
there I agree but she is a little I
enjoyed meeting her I find her to be one
of the the Queen's of the Housewives she
is I have yet to meet Vicki Gunvalson
that is going to be you better yeah no I
have not I have not we got a good report
of a yard that is gonna be excited
we do some street meat
yes drunk dance on top of the cooler and
and and have a lot of trouble like like
walking off a curb right it's great oh
that was you know what's funny it was
really funny watching Orange County this
season because I mean and I loved her
but that was Shannon beador
low point is she was divorced going to
Andales whooping it all whoop it up
trying to like get her mojo back
and I had a drunken night at on delays
like and then like the high of like
dancing on the bar and getting naked
like that that' quested and then they're
eating street meat and sitting in a
plastic chair and she started crying
about like david and all that stuff and
I was like okay the only way to go from
here is up and this is like I'm ready
for this ride we're gonna see we're
gonna see the Phoenix rise now she's
gonna get a career going keep you saying
she's gonna get a product going she's
getting in great shape
she's as if you follow her on social
media it's not on the show she's got you
know a dude in her life if you watched
Orange County last week she went on a
date with a hot guy Shama doe was also
married for 30 years in divorce like it
was really fun to watch that street made
scene yes in Mexico because you knew it
that was rock bottom dude that was rock
bottom okay also you recently went viral
for leaving a rave review at TomTom oh
yeah what would you recommend ordering
it's like you can only get one thing
well um just get the drinks there you
know I do have to say it was very
exciting for me
I recently again went back to TomTom
with captain Lee studied below deck Wow
prestigious we went there and someone at
the restaurant told both not one but
both Tom's that we were there and they
came and brought like specialty drinks
to our table and it was really amazing
to see IRL tom sand of all saying like
um what we have here is a watermelon
imputed it it's Alec yer with a little
bit about um orange orange ah fizzy
drink put in there and with a little bit
of mint and we do it's just gonna be so
palatable for you remember and it was
really fun to have them bring their like
special Tom Tom specialty drinks so I
would say go there to have their crazy
drinks and get your drink on there by
the way Tom super fun experience
everybody's dressed up they everyone
dresses like Lala when they go in there
a lot of my rings and it's like a real
Hollywood night out I highly highly
suggested you know okay la is like
famous for like hey man hey bro just
gonna flip flops and tease ya I don't
care I just got off the beats me I don't
care like we're laying back here it's
just all I need is a tan and a little
bit of concealer boom I'm out um at Tom
Tom everybody puts an effort upscale
here for it okay one more question were
gonna bring it back to Bravo to get
everyone ready for play-by-play nights
on Bravo
is there any Bravo show that you don't
watch or you don't like this is such a
great question and really the first time
I've gotten it and I have to be super
careful answering this what am I gonna
say um what are you gonna say I'm gonna
go with it I did not watch one episode
ok yes sure Tyrone with love you know
actually that was a pretty cool in my
friend Brian play he is [ __ ] obsessed
he swears that to Roma Club is the best
show on TV to Roman was pretty cool
pretty cool married to medicine is
so pretty high drama no they're insane
it's a good shape it's a good show let
me just tell you last season a couple
was announced they were getting divorced
huh during the reunion and everyone was
crying and upset and the whole reunion
turned on them and begged them to get
stay together and they stayed together
yeah I mean honestly my wife and I might
just go to a married to medicine reunion
- like what work on our marriage they're
like they're really a housewives like
they're also a rarity it's also a very
bout
it's crazy because their doctor actual
doc they're real like doctors it's not
like fake doctors like saying they're
doctors like I'm the doctor of love like
the seller like like Oh Ross Geller
he's PhDs a doctor well I mean if you do
have a right if you do have a doctorate
you can't call yourself we got a real
doctor these are like medicine
practicing doctors and dentists and
stuff but it's an extremist volatile
show on Bravo like the fights are fights
like altercations yes crazy but what's
the show you don't know shows you don't
much you know what apres ski oh that's
so funny whatever we see a show like
whoever came up with that idea
no no it's obvious it like that was not
one of the shows and II like produces
honestly I gave it like literally
minutes and I was like no I'm not doing
it but no one cares no one cares about
you apres ski
that's so funny I did I think you were
gonna say that but that was an epic
answer thank you for being here
Hey ladies as they say in sports radio
like first-time caller longtime listener
really proud of everything you do thank
you well make sure to tune in to
play-by-play on Bravo
Monday night what time 10:00 p.m. Tempe
and also follow Jerry that Real
Housewives of Orange County on instagram
at mr. Jerry OC yeah mr. Jerry Orange
County that's how you can remember it
thank you guys for clearly had a half
side view Boney's do you want me to
change your name make sure you're
watching the morning toast Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on Facebook and YouTube we're live
streamed and we're also available in the
podcast app so make sure I'm son last
question for your live shows like where
do we go to get tickets for that Oh
Jerry I thought you'd never ask
and you know I'm I already sold out six
shows in New York but if I do come back
I'll send you and Rebecca some tickets
says but girl with no job calm I'm
headed to DC Albany Buffalo Huntsville
leland and around finishing it up at two
sold-out nights at the Wilbur theater in
Boston and I just I don't know it's just
it's exciting so head over to girl time
job comm to get tickets ticket you're
asking thank you guys so much for
watching how many amazing weekend people
see you Monday
you